je suis ravi de faire partie de cette
aventure qui avant tout humaine et puis
voilà on chantait moi c'est annick et
puis bah j'ai hâte de faire votre
connaissance à tous et à toutes vraiment
rien demandé paca il a plus ou moins
mythique c'est toi maintenant ça mais
tant qu'on fasse un jeu d'éveil pour se
remonter le moral et gallagher le seul
accroc ce que je regarde moi les jeux
fait d'amis qui tente le cheval peut
t'aider non non vous même en tout cas
c'est magnifique tu peux me permettre
theft auto menthol clic
pardon je vous ai coupé grosse à rien
c'est juste un manque de respect inouï
annick
et on est deuxième en format web on
regarde pas ce qu'on appelle c'est le
mensonge le vrai ennemi mais qu'est ce
qu'elle à l'appui du bricolage peut être
la cheffe de l'animation sera la chef de
ton cul et tu vis tes pas aller au dodo
annick qu'est ce tu fais exprès de
clochards de la sorte de la bête balazs
mon avis banane je n'ai pas même pas
dans la merde et cool hausse légale et
par là je vais pas en parler c'est le
spectacle avant tout les fêtes un
spectacle dans ton coin s'te plaît
pardon je raccroche pauv'con ou à la
grève tu prends tes affaires et tu te
casses on a fait tous première cause de
toi tu veux rester non donc tu prends
ton gros cul ton sac en jute tôt
flambeau tu viens ici tu te casses nous
convoque pas constitue veut combattre
regarde voilà bel et bien mort 1 2 3 4
sa limite et c'est vrai
avoir des bombes allaient comment ça me
rend l'âme et non mais tu veux quoi un
bisou ici allez hop tu te casses il mêle
à l'aventuré s'arrête ici et maintenant
new york à toi tu prends tes fèves et et
raisins secs et tu rentres à montélimar